at site 19 many anomalies are kept
secure
one however does not fit in with the
rest he is a caucasian man of around 55
years of age who at first glance seems
normal in
every way he's average height average
weight
and dressed in business attire calling
himself gustav noble
he seems to be a perfectly pleasant
american man who seems to be deeply out
of place
compared to the hundreds of other
objects and entities kept at the largest
scp containment facility so why is he
so closely guarded what secrets are kept
inside this man's head
to understand why scp-657 is so
important one has to go back to his
recovery mr noble worked for years
as an undertaker at a funeral home in
the united states
not raising any attention but there was
a man who worked for him
and they didn't get along they argued
frequently
and one day scp-652 had to correct the
man's work
something that he had to do frequently
they argued and suddenly mr noble got
angry
he yelled out what does it matter you'll
be dead before the end of the week
there were multiple people present and
they all thought mr noble must be losing
his mind
that is until it came true
three days later the man was working on
his home when he slipped and fell from
his roof
he was killed instantly in what would
seem like a tragic
accident there was no evidence pointing
to another cause of death
but many people remembered mr noble's
outburst at work
and reported him to the authorities as a
possible killer
that was enough for the police and they
arrested mr noble
they were never able to find any
physical evidence linking him to the
case
but they questioned him relentlessly
while he never indicated that he was
responsible
mr noble did make similar comments about
one of the arresting officers
also being close to death that man met
his own end
two days later when a suspect fatally
shot him during an apprehension
the two deaths seemed unrelated but the
police didn't believe it
and neither did the scp foundation
the police were convinced that this
normal-looking man had somehow been
involved in the officer's death
and they made a request for federal
assistance as they investigated
while they didn't understand what had
happened they knew they wanted to see
the man pay
for his crimes the justice system moved
quickly
and gustav noble was put on trial for
both murders
in near-record time he was convicted of
one murder and of conspiracy to commit
the other
and he was sentenced to death according
to the officers who apprehended him
he would soon be facing the death
chamber and justice would be done but it
was all
a lie the scp foundation is quite
experienced with extracting prisoners
condemned prisoners are one of their
best sources for the recruiting of
d-class personnel
and they know how to remove a prisoner
from incarceration and leave the
authorities no clue that anything went
awry
they used those procedures to retrieve
mr noble before his date with the
executioner
but unlike most inmates the foundation
plucks from death row
this one wasn't headed for d-class duty
the foundation believed he was much more
important than that
they knew that this man who would soon
be classified as scp-657
had a unique link to death itself
once secured at site 19 scp-657 was
debriefed and
investigated by foundation officials
which is when they became aware of the
full extent of his abilities
scp-657 had the ability to predict the
time of anyone's death
sometimes with terrifying accuracy all
it takes for him to make a prediction
is for him to make physical contact with
the person
which can be something as simple as
shaking their hand
the prediction is involuntary as soon as
he makes contact
he gets the information about how much
longer they have to live
he was able to predict the deaths of the
two men he had made contact with
down to the day but when exposed to some
d-class personnel who had already been
slated for termination the next day
he was able to make predictions down to
the minute
but there was one weak spot in scp-657's
predictions
the closer the person he makes contact
with is to their moment of death
the more accurate he is but that works
in reverse as well
if he touches someone who is still far
away from their time of death
his predictions get fuzzier he can still
predict the general time of death
but if it's a decade or more away all he
can see is the year
with no more details no matter how
accurate the time he gives
is he never gets any other information
such as the cause of death all he gets
is a number
inside his head but while the details
might be unclear
they are no less accurate and every
prediction as cp
657 has made about the time of death has
been proven
true scp-657's powers seem to work the
same on every living person
although there are a few odd exceptions
when tested on a select few scp agents
and doctors
he claimed that his abilities came up
empty he simply couldn't see a time of
death for them
and the investigations and testing
proved he was telling the truth
this indicates that future
investigations about these flukes
should center not on scp-657 but on the
individuals who seem to be immune
so far though no common link or
explanation
has been found between them other than
the fact that they all work for the
foundation
what does stay consistent is the
reaction people have to scp
657 when encountering him people will
nearly always report that they find him
strange
unpleasant or creepy they may be sensing
his abilities
even if they're not aware of them but
when they're informed that he can
predict the time of death
the unsettling feeling seems to escalate
when they don't know
they simply can't identify what causes
them to have this disturbing feeling
could this be a milder but similar
effect to that caused by scp-053
a small child who makes otherwise stable
people feel compelled to act violently
right now the reaction people have to
scp-657 is not considered a source of
concern
but the foundation is keeping an eye on
it scp-657
is an unusual specimen in other ways too
though
and that requires unusual protocols
scp-657 is one of the lowest security
residents at site 19
with his living quarters being a large
room with a queen-size
bed and any reasonable amenities he
requests
he's not considered a threat to escape
and displays no hostility
so the main concern is keeping him
healthy and stable for future testing
his nutritional needs are taken care of
with the staff providing him with daily
meals and vitamins
along with medication for his arthritis
his quarters look closer to a hotel room
than to a cell
and initially he was able to move around
site 19 as he wished
as long as he was accompanied by a staff
member of proper security
so why did this have to change nothing
differed in scp-652
behavior and no attempts to escape or
security breaches were made
however what did become clear was that
scp-657 freely wandering around the
facility was
a danger not to others but to himself
if he encountered the wrong being this
stems from an experiment where scp-657
was introduced to scp-076
better known as abel and he is one of
the most volatile scps
in site 19. scp-076 consists of two
separate
entities a black cube of engraved stone
and the human-like heavily tattooed male
figure that resides inside it
while able spends most of his time
dormant in a death-like state
he occasionally awakens and seeks out
the nearest human being
which he then seeks to kill unless he
himself is terminated
when killed he eventually reincarnates
within the cube
scp-076 is a puzzle to the foundation
and they thought scp-657 could help them
answer it scp-657 was introduced to
scp-076-2
as the humanoid able is officially
designated
under pretenses of having him join
mobile task force omega 7
an experimental team consisting of some
powerful but controllable
scps this was really a way to see if
scp-657 could answer
any questions about scp-076-2's lifespan
given the being supernatural nature and
unique resurrection
process it's not a huge surprise that
the answer
was no what was a surprise was how
scp-657 reacted
the process of determining someone's
lifespan is usually quick and easy
for scp-657 the numbers will usually
appear in his mind in
just seconds but when he touched
scp-076-2
things went very wrong his eyes
immediately rolled back into his head
and he collapsed there was no physical
cause for this
but he fell into a coma and didn't wake
up for over a week
after he woke up he was examined for any
lingering health issues and
interviewed so the foundation could
learn what he experienced
it turned out the answer was that he
experienced
nothing he had no memory of the events
or of even meeting scp-076-2 at all
this indicates that either scp-657's
abilities won't work on anything that's
not
technically human or that scp-076-2
simply doesn't have a lifespan
and will continue to reincarnate forever
it was clear that scp-657 had an
achilles heel
exposure to human-like but ultimately
inhuman scps had the potential to mess
with his abilities
and create serious adverse side effects
while this time he had recovered in only
a week
no one knew if the next time would cause
lasting damage
it was determined that security measures
needed to be increased
scp-657 would be confined to his
quarters
with two security staff members
stationed outside his door at all times
as scp-657 had no unusual or
dangerous physical abilities security is
still minimal compared to other scps
and the foundation has instructed the
site to grant all reasonable requests
for entertainment
and furnishments to ensure his mental
health stays stable
but there is one other thing the
foundation is still trying to avoid
the staff has been ordered to keep their
distance from scp-657
and avoid physical contact unless
absolutely necessary
this is because accidental contact
giving scp-657
access to the death information could be
stressful for both parties
the knowledge of someone's pending death
has been shown to weigh heavy on
scp-657 as seen in his initial outburst
against his employee
and not everyone wants to know how much
time they have left
minimal physical contact is the best way
to preserve
scp-657's use to the scp
foundation so what are the long-term
plans for scp-657
there are still many unanswered
questions about his ability
well he has now been prohibited from
interacting with other non-human scps
for his own safety
he could still be used by the foundation
to learn vital information about
foundation agents
and the danger posed to them on upcoming
missions
one question is can the death date be
altered with advanced knowledge
for instance could an agent who is
slated to die in two days on a mission
be switched off that mission to change
their death date
or would this create a time paradox
potentially upsetting reality by trying
to change it
these and many other experiments will
likely be tried by the foundation
in the future once a safe method for
testing them is developed
and approved the research continues
though
since the best chance the scp foundation
has at answering the great mysteries of
death
may just rest in the unassuming older
man in
sight 19. for more on another unassuming
old man with unique abilities
check out scp-662 butler's handbell
or watch scp-053 young girl
for more on that strange case